-Hey, everybody, welcome back
to the show.
Just a reminder, we have
a new thing we're doing
called the Fallon Book Club.
We're starting a book club.
Yesterday, we announced
our very first book --
"Tomorrow and Tomorrow and
Tomorrow" by Gabrielle Zevin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna be reading this
over the next few weeks.
I started reading it
a little bit.
-When, last night?
-No, this is --
like, a couple weeks ago.
I did a little research.
I had to start a little bit,
just so I know what book
I want to choose
for the book club,
but this is the one.
This is the jam.
It's a love story-ish.
Well, it's like --
it's set in the '90s.
These two kids haven't seen
each other in a while.
They know each other
from school.
They're computer nerds.
They start a video game
together.
They create a video game
together,
and then you see what happens.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
You know what I liked about it,
though, is the line in here --
he sees this girl he hasn't seen
since grade school or something
or high school,
and he sees her on the train
and he yells out her name.
He's like, "Sadie Green,"
and she doesn't turn around.
He's like, "Sadie Green."
He goes, "Sadie Green,
you died of dysentery."
And she turns around
'cause if anyone --
Do you remember that game --
"Oregon Trail"?
-Oh, yeah.
-So it's like a good --
it's a really funny line.
I go, "Oh, that's
a good reference."
So anyways, so it's like that.
It's well-written. It's good.
If you want to follow along
with me,
pick up a copy,
go to your local library.
I will be posting updates
on my socials
to let you know where I'm at
and what I think of the book.
Then later, we'll have
the author, Gabrielle Zevin,
on the show to talk about it.
It is the Fallon Book Club.
-Oh!
-It is gonna be fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
FBC! FBC!